d'un côté bonsoir bienvenue à 24,60 au
mois d'août le giec nous disait que la
chaîne alimentaire comptait pour le
tiers des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et donc il y avait de grandes
inquiétudes que les peut-être changer
notre façon de produire l'alimentation
aujourd'hui d'autres études vient nous
dire de manière plus nuancée qui a
peut-être différents modèles différents
scénarios comment accueillez vous cette
étude aujourd'hui je l'accueille très
favorablement parce que ce qu'elle giec
nous disait cet été c'est que pour
sauver la planète faudrait qu'on mange
beaucoup moins de viande qu'on mange
plus d'aliments végétaux mais c'est sûr
qu'une recommandation comme celle là ne
fait pas en sorte que tout le monde va
devenir végétarien deux jours elle d'une
journée à l'autre
alors ce que l'étude aujourd'hui
d'aujourd'hui nous dit c'est que on peut
nuancer ce message là de dire oui on
peut manger moins de viande mangée plus
de végétaux sans nécessairement devenir
végétarien mais nuancé je commençais
mais ça et dans les scénarios envisagés
il ya ceux qui s'occupent aussi de
l'urgence alimentaire sur le continent
où on connaît des famines de chez des
femmes enceintes les enfants qui sont
mal nourris et l'urgence climatique
commence et conciliable ou pas la
conciliation entre la santé et le défi
climatique doit être personnalisé d'un
pays à l'autre entre autres l'étude nous
fait
mention de l'état de l'inde entre autres
où il ya énormément de malnutrition de
femmes enceintes et d'enfants qui n'ont
pas qu'ils ont de la misère à combler
leurs besoins
on peut pas leur demander à ces
populations de manger moins de viande
parce qu'elles ont besoin davantage donc
faut vraiment moduler le message en
fonction des besoins des ressources
aussi des pays ici au canada dans un
pays industrialisé
on est en mesure de recommander aux gens
de manger moins de viande de faire plus
de place aux aliments végétaux sans
nuire à l'état de leur santé et ça
évidemment c'est primordial parce que
notre modèle nous nous mène à la
catastrophe quand même sur le plan
climatique se comprend bien oui oui
carrément manger que commence tous
beaucoup de viande à toutes les semaines
qu'on mange énormément de boeuf aussi
qui est la viande lait la plus
dommageable pour l'environnement
oui tout ça nous fait un peu foncer dans
le mur donc sans nécessairement arrêter
de manger de la viande ou du poulet ou
du poisson
je pense que le message de 2,2 tous
faire un petit effort de manger moins de
viande
en fait l'étude nous disait aussi que le
modèle qui semble le plus efficace pour
diminuer notre empreinte carbone c'est
d'adopter une alimentation aux deux
tiers végétalienne donc deux repas par
jour manger strictement des aliments
végétaux mais un repas par jour manger
comme un homme me voir donc oui intégrée
de la viande une fois de temps en temps
du poisson tout en privilégiant les
animaux qui sont en bas de la chaîne
alimentaire le bien sûr on va sourciller
parce qu'on va parler d'un scellé aussi
de mollusques qui est quand même délit
petits poissons la rend les sardines qui
sont quand même des dépôts compromis
qu'on peut faire puis tout en ne perdant
paul le goût aussi le plaisir de manger
parce que socke six ans dans la balance
et en même temps vous est venue de nice
vous savez à quel point il est difficile
de changer les habitudes alimentaires
1 comment perçoivent ces changements là
les personnes comment les personnes qui
reçoivent tels ces changements quand on
parle de changements qui sont graduelles
des changements de petits pas et qu'on
offre à la population des compromis on
n'est pas en train de dire à tout le
monde devine est végétarien là c'est sûr
que quand on construit
devant vraiment une population qui est
très réfractaire puis nous c'est
probablement donc de suggérer aux gens
de manger moins de viande de faire plus
de place aux végétaux d'y aller vraiment
avec la découverte de nouveaux aliments
pu y aller par le les saveurs et le
plaisir est de continuer à savoir qu'on
peut bien manger
je pense que c'est de cette façon ils
voyaient comme étant le mode ou une
tendance lors peut-être chez les plus
jeunes générations vers le végétarisme
ou végétalien oui le végétarisme est en
grande évolution le végétalisme donc
levé vraiment de ne pas manger aucun
produit animal ou soignies malsaucy
étant est un grand développement il y a
des raisons climatiques la dent may et
des raisons d'éthique animal et où donc
plusieurs motivations
mais oui ça c'est que tu n'es vraiment
c'est une mode est plus qu'une mode vrai
c'est un mouvement qui est en
développement mais c'est encore un petit
pourcentage la population cela dit même
si ça augmente la lumière fût beaucoup
venus goûter aux plaisirs